trong thông gà là đi mê của chiên nề mùng sau thông mì một, yêu cầu cửa cụ qua liên quan sân tích tình mũ của tổng mỹ đường nân trăm,
về việc nối lại thử dệ vũ kiệp nhân và để sốt phương án ứng phó.
Ngà khẳng định vẫn tôn thu hề bước cấm thử hạm nhân toàn diện.
Tâm sẵn sáng hành động tương sứng, nếu Mỹ khởi động thử nghiệp.
Bôi trường của phòng gà, anh truyền, beroe sốt cho biết,
tất sở thử nghiệp, bãi ngu vây gà, chếm lia, có thể hoạt động trở lại trong thời gian.
Truy đó, điện khém liên cho biết Mỹ đã thông báo trước trong ngày,
về kế hoạch phóng thử tế lời đảnh đạo li lục biển Mỹ đến MEN TRI,
không mang đầu đạn hạm nhân.
Theo quy định của tế, thì những loại tế lời trở lượng bắt bộ phải của thông báo,
nhằm chẳng nhiều lâm dựa các khu rà hạm nhân.
Công ngành tình báo hàn của kỉnh báo, chú tiên đang có số hiệu trình bị chương một vụ thử hạm nhân mới,
tại cơ sở, phung gí ri, dơ chương sân nhìn định,
đột phải này cho thấy căn thằng hạm nhân toàn cầu đang bước phá dự đạn nhệ càng khi các cường quốc điều
cân nhát hả năng tái khởi đồng các trình trình thử nghiệp sau hơn bà thập kỉnh giản đoạn.